I'm really happy to be here today to
talk to you about food and nutrient
databases it's appropriate since you're
probably all coming off your sugar high
from your cookies outside food and
nutrient databases are important part of
infrastructure for food and nutrient
research which informs public policy the
data also allows consumers to be
informed and better control their diet
which as we all know plays an important
role in the prevention and treatment of
diseases such as cancer cardiovascular
disease and diabetes first a little bit
about who we are the nutrition
coordinating center is part of the
University of Minnesota School of Public
Health we just celebrated our 40th
anniversary founded in nineteen seventy
four to support two large clinical
trials evaluating the effect of diet on
blood lipid levels and cardiovascular
disease our mission is to develop
provide and support state-of-the-art
methods and databases for researchers
for the collection and analysis of
dietary data
there are many aspects of food and
nutrient databases and today I'm going
to focus on telling you what a food and
nutrient database is how these databases
are used and talked about one challenge
that we have that food and drink
databases have and that's completeness
versus comprehensiveness and then some
of the solutions to this challenge so
first what is a food and nutrient
database this is a database that
quantifies the nutrient composition of
foods in this example data is shown for
a hundred grams of banana which is about
90 calories you'll see on here protein
fat carbohydrate and dietary fiber those
are known as the macronutrients there's
also some vitamins and minerals and it
looks like a lot of nutrients up there
but this is really only the tip of the
iceberg the of nutrients that can be
quantified for example in addition to
protein or fat you can break those down
into all the individual amino acids or
individual fatty acids all of those
could be quantified just so you know
nutrition coordinating center is a is a
big name to keep saying so I will
occasionally for brevity's sake refer to
this as the NCC database our database
has 165 nutrients
food and nutrient databases are used for
many different purposes I'll briefly
review some of the more common uses
you're probably most familiar with
nutrition labeling the FDA regulates
package labeling and nutrition labels
can have up to 32 nutrients
manufacturers may analyze foods to
obtain nutrient data that they use on
the labels but often they calculate
nutrient values from ingredients used in
the formulation and some food businesses
rely solely on food and nutrient
databases in order to determine label
information echa is an example of a
database that is widely used for this
purpose as it contains many industry
food ingredients food and nutrient
databases are also used for various
types of diet trackers these have
primarily focused on energy or calorie
consumption they're often combined with
activity monitors such as pedometers how
many of you like me and have your
fitbit's on today or maybe your Garmin
or your jawbone devices as this market
develops apps are being developed for
more specific populations for example
people with diabetes would be interested
in knowing the glycemic index or people
with high cholesterol might be
interested in knowing total fat
saturated fat and cholesterol in their
diet food and nutrient databases are you
utilized for all types of research you
can just take a look at some of the news
headlines and see that some of the
research is being done but also if you
go to NCC's website we have posted a
list of studies that we've been involved
in another research aspect that utilizes
food and nutrient databases is nutrition
surveillance basically within nutrition
surveillance we're asking what and how
much people are eating and
this often informs public policy the Ann
Haynes study is one that probably all of
you have heard of it stands for the
national health and nutrition
examination survey and it's a
government-funded study sponsored by the
national center for health statistics
and CDC CDC is currently very interested
in sodium reduction also energy intake
and obesity a more a privately funded
study is that you may have heard about
this nutrition surveillance study is
fits which is danced for feeding infants
and toddlers and it's a Gerber study
funded now by Nestle research since
Nestle owns Gerber another example of
uses for food and nutrient databases as
menu planning for institutions oops
sorry I'm ahead of myself medical
management of diseases this in this
example a example of kidney stones some
of which are formed from oxalates and
calcium people with these types of
stones or advice to minimize their
intake of foods that are rich in oxalate
food nutrient databases then support
patient education regarding foods for
which consumption must be limited now
we're to menu planning this is another
use of food and nutrient databases menus
are needed in schools prisons for
nursing homes or other health facilities
the military and even for astronauts
perhaps someday a colony on Mars there
are a variety of different databases
that are available there are actually
over a hundred different food and
nutrient databases they are unique in
their content and sources of data and
they fulfill different needs many of
these are listed online in the National
nutrient databank conference data bank
directory and I have the website listed
at the end of my presentation under
resources so if you are interested in
looking at that database you can see or
at the database directory you can see
all the different types of databases
that are out there I am just going to
briefly mention a couple of the public
ones that people are utilizing and that
includes the USDA SR database SR
standing for standard reference database
this is really an important resource for
all food and nutrient databases a lot of
their data is analytical as comes from
the nutrient data lab and that is the
best type of data to have another one is
the what we eat in America study which
utilize the FN dds food and nutrient
database for dietary studies that's what
FN dds stands for database and so those
are two of the most prominent public
databases are available private
databases 1 i'll just mention is the
glass and database has over 200,000
foods primarily it's used to organize
supermarket shelf space but when
manufacturers submit information about
new products they also include the
nutrient panel information and
ingredient information the unfortunate
thing is that if the package if they do
introduce a new food product and the
package size doesn't change then they
don't necessarily update the nutrition
information so some of the information
in that database we found to not be as
up-to-date as we would would want it's
also very expensive and then the essure
database I already mentioned that once
widely used by food food manufacturers
to to do nutrition labeling all of these
different database food nutrient
databases have some common needs and so
out I'll just briefly talk about that
and it's really these are things that
that a lot of them need even if the
regardless of what application that they
have databases need to include the foods
of the Americans eat if the research is
being done in the US we need to have
food in the database that people eat
there's more than 30,000 food products
in typical American supermarket and
close to forty percent of the calories
Americans eat now come from meals eaten
away from home so restaurant foods are
an important part of any food and
nutrient database
the database should also include ethnic
foods there's growing diversity among
the American population and the American
palate so it's crucial for most
databases to include both ethnic foods
and regional foods food nutrient
databases also need to be kept current
with the marketplace you think about a
lot of data it goes into the database
and you're done it's in there it's
always in there with food and nutrient
data you really need to have a good
maintenance strategy because foods
change there's new products entering the
market place on an ongoing basis and
existing products are undergoing
reformulations for example many
manufacturers are now reformulating
their products to lower their sodium
content those are all changes that need
to be made in the database databases
should also have a high level of
completeness does the database include
the nutrients that are needed for
example in a kidney stone example that I
gave earlier if you were someone who had
kidney stones you would want to know how
much oxalic acid was in foods is that in
their database or not and how complete
are the nutrient data for foods in the
database so if it does contain oxalic
acid is it ten percent of the foods
there for ten percent of foods or is it
there for a hundred percent of the foods
because if it's only ten percent it's
not really particularly useful
it's this last area in nutrient
completeness I want to talk about a
little more there's often a seesaw
effect between complete and
comprehensive databases comprehensive
describes how many foods are in the
database wires completeness describes
the nutrients available and how complete
the nutrient data is so a database like
gladson which I described which has over
200,000 foods would definitely be a
comprehensive database but it only has
label nutrients so it's not very
complete complete it doesn't have very
many nutrients likewise the more
complete that a database is in terms of
having more nutrients and more data for
each food the less comprehensive or the
fewer foods it often has so this is the
seesaw issue if we look at a comparison
of completeness for a few of the
different databases you can see that
Asia is very comprehensive with 40,000
Foods in it but it lacks some
completeness for many nutrients such as
vitamin D which is only twenty percent
and their other nutrients that are
similar to that whereas NCC database is
unusual and as strikes a balance it has
more than twice as many foods SF and dds
database and more nutrients than either
the f'n dds or esha with almost all the
nutrients available for all foods in
other words near a hundred percent
complete for all nutrients for all foods
so one of the features of the NCC
database that makes it the choice of
researchers is a small number of missing
nutrient values how do we achieve a
balance between comprehensiveness and
completeness there is no one magic
bullet but I will describe to you how
NCC works toward achieving ways both
kind of balancing comprehensiveness and
completeness is too bad those words both
start with C they're confusing isn't it
the NCC food and nutrient database
includes almost one hundred percent
complete values for 165 nutrients we use
various sources of information other
database of scientific literature
manufacturer websites other ways to make
complete nutrients strings for these
foods is to use values from a similar
food for example if you're missing a
nutrient for wild duck it may be judged
that that the same the same as a no
nutrient for domestic duck or we may
calculate values from other components
in the same food for example we want to
know vitamin A but we don't have vitamin
A but we have carotenoids we can
sometimes calculate some of those values
and there are a few other tricks that we
also use for making defining that
information and making our data complete
but today I want to talk a little bit
more about what how we do this for brand
name and restaurant foods because those
are really growing and expanding and
very difficult to get more than the
label nutrients so how do we go about
getting that information we essentially
reverse engineer foods to create food
formulations or recipes if you look at a
food label the ingredients are listed in
descending order of content in the
product so there's more the ingredients
at the top of the label are more than
at the bottom of the label down here so
we keep that in mind and then we have a
food calculation program that estimates
ingredient amounts that follow the
ingredient statement constraints and
produce a recipe with a nutrient
composition profile that closely matches
the nutrition facts panel information we
also have a very experienced team of
nutrition database scientists who use a
program as well as their judgment and
knowledge to resolve missing nutrients
so in other words I'm saying this is not
a program which is just a push of the
button and it makes a decision on what
those nutrients are there is a lot of
expertise is also involved in this but
this food calculation program is very
helpful and is something that is pretty
unique to ncc ncc database has about
2700 core foods and this is one of the
things that allows us to reverse
engineer formulations for brand-name
foods we have a comprehensive core foods
or have a comprehensive nutrient
composition and it's primarily based on
an analytical data and these core foods
are the building blocks for creating
nutrient composition values for these
multi ingredient foods so in this case
for a pizza we have oops bec we have
flour and oil and sugar and salt and
water to make the dough to come up with
a formulation and then pepperoni and
cheese and spaghetti sauce until we come
up with the final formulation for a
pizza in a nutshell this is our MCC
solution to the challenge of
completeness in our database
there are a few other challenges that
databases have I'll just mention a
couple of them one is the language used
to describe foods some descriptions have
hundreds of characters if you're an
application developer you need short
food descriptions and the descriptions
need to be unique and that gets more
difficult as the database adds more
foods NCC has just actually added short
food descriptions to our database which
makes it a little bit easier and another
another challenge is currency we are
currently adding new foods and updating
nutrient data in the database it's a
very big job and future considerations
that I think need to be considered is
our brand name food products database
and although the food industry has
compositional data for their own
products very little that data is
actually publicly available or it may be
difficult to gather the USDA and ill see
international life sciences institute
and a group called a tip which is
agricultural technology innovation
partnership are forming a public-private
partnership to help make this data
available it's still uncertain whether
funding will be there to make this
happen international databases I think
this is another big area a lot of people
who researchers who are working
internationally often have to build
their own study databases and term and
specific food formulations obviously the
language difference and also differences
in nutrient fortification levels present
difficulties one group called n foods
international network of food data
systems which is part of the food and
agriculture organization of the united
nations has tried to compile some of
this in
formation and I did list several
resources this includes the nutrition
coordinating Center website we have a
lot of information there the National
nutrient data bank conference database
directory the USDA sr database a link to
FM dds database and a link to Food and
Agricultural organization which is the
international databases